[Music]
imagine losing months of sleep and
slowly losing your mind
because you can't stop gambling fake
gold
chasing a digital payday that's never
going to happen
you said you would leave if you lost so
leave stop challenging him
inshallah you lose dude no don't say
that
no why would you say that every single
day that debt piles up it follows you
around
sitting like a weight on your shoulders
and despite doing everything you can to
get out of it you can't escape the fact
that you are
well and truly screwed i legitimately
think from how much stress
i went through for that debt i went both
and you know
you only have two choices you can either
run from the fans who loaned you vast
amounts of cash
or you can dig yourself out of a 205
billion gold hole and for oda block
it was time to start digging
for trusting me yes
yes
today
who knows what was our highest set that
we've ever had at one point
on the on the set list 258
258 bills at one point
and now we're at 29. i don't know
nothing i'm just free
free i see your brother thank you
i see i see
now over the last 19 years runescape the
point-and-click adventure game
has earned a cult-like following and a
thriving twitch community to go along
with it
and one popular aspect of the game is
the dual arena which is exactly what it
sounds like
people fighting it out one on one finish
them off
no no no no no no no
no oh my god
[Music]
and this right here is something called
staking which is where you stake or
gamble sometimes vast amounts of gold or
items in the dual arena
you and one other person challenge each
other right you guys set the same exact
rules you guys have the same exact
weapon
and it's just random random number
generator whatever you hit you hit you
guys both start at 99 health
first to zero like loses the stake so
the other person
has to put you to zero help and it's
just you using the same weapon whoever
hits hits whoever doesn't does it
and it's here where you can sometimes
find otablock one of runescape's most
popular streamers
oh what the hell what
in the world of runescape and pvp in
particular
oda block is something of a legend
okay is that it
shut the [ __ ] down the idiot holy
holy holy [ __ ] from his unique
personality and antics on stream
to his incredible skill murdering people
in game
when he takes his cash back to the sand
casino otablock frequently combines the
holy [ __ ]
factor of gambling billions of gold like
it's nothing
with his truly out there personality and
shenanigans
oh my god that's the biggest one i've
ever had oh my god
oh my god man any four pillar win no
no man oh my god ben now
just because oda block is a legend in
the dual arena doesn't mean he doesn't
lose
because he does like a lot like being
258 billion gold in debt
a lot yeah you heard that right at one
point in time
oda block was 258 billion gold
in debt four or five years ago was when
i found out about the dual arena and
then i started like
you know like anything i had like i
would just chuck it to the sky like
like let's just say like this is why i'm
not a gambler in real life because if i
was like i'd be like chucking my kidney
my right leg
like i'm kind of crazy bro i don't know
when to stop so it's like
i'm not a gambling life i would never
gamble but in terms of like runescape
once i found out about it like i don't
stop till i'm up
now i know you might hear 258 billion
gold and think
who cares this is a fake currency in a
popular game
but here's the thing runescape has an
intricate economy and gold
by saying getting breaking the rules can
actually be converted into cold hard
cash and to be crystal clear buying and
selling gold
using these shady third-party websites
is a big
no-no and you're likely to have your
account banned if developer jagex
catches you doing it
in runescape that is not allowed that's
called billboard trade it's a rule that
you can't do
but let's be honest all these guys in
the underground scene everywhere they
ex fake odd steak and all these stakers
they usually all break that rule
and make a lot of money irl or buy into
the game try to make money than cash out
which is bannable but there is a legal
way to buy gold
see jagex sells in-game items called
bonds for real money
which you can turn around and sell for
in-game currency
so for the sake of an explanation that
258 billion gold that oda block owed
according to him with bonds worth 6.99
his debt equaled to over 200 000 actual
dollars i would i would say my debt
if i would were to buy bonds on the game
like to make it like you know
allowed it was well over 200k now while
oda block did the math off the top of
his head
according to our math calculated by my
producer alex's
dad his gold debt was actually worth
three hundred and ten thousand
nine hundred and thirty four dollars and
48 cents
and a big reason why real world trading
is against the rules
is because they would essentially tank
the in-game economy that jagex has
created
imagine if they allowed rural trade that
means people could sell and buy gold to
each other bonds would be useless and
they would make less money
you're cutting them a brother you can't
be doing that don't be playing with
somebody's money
now oda block acquired all his gold to
gamble a few different ways
for one he's an incredibly talented risk
fighter
just like the dual arena risk fighting
is what it sounds like
two people risking items or money in a
fight to the death
the difference between staking and risk
fighting is that risk fighting isn't
about a 50 50 chance
it's more of a traditional fight to the
death based on skill
and god damn is he good at it i'm
actually like one of the best like
killing people for a big amount of money
i would risk a big amount of money they
would risk a big amount of money
and um and i would i would we've battled
it out
and it's like mostly skilled because you
have to know what you're doing how to
eat food
how to utilize this or that and i would
make a lot of money from that then chuck
it to the sky
and hopefully make bank every day i
literally went live every day i did not
miss a day no matter the stress or
where i was going the other way he got
his gambling gold was from his community
see oda block has been streaming
runescape for years at this point and
his community is loyal beyond belief
and because of that love for him a lot
of them have no problem loaning him gold
to continue his staking adventures
most of these guys i knew them from my
stream they're cool people i'm
definitely paying them back it was
literally it was literally
like a list like it literally looked
like it was on some john wick [ __ ] like
i gotta pay this guy back buddy
this guy this guy this guy's next this
guy's next like it was crazy like i'm
not even gonna
and despite sort of being against the
rules but also kind of not
the practice of loaning streamers gold
in runescape
is pretty common i'm not gonna lie my
compute my community like
one of the most generous communities
ever so like there's a lot of people who
like
helped me out was like yo chuck my money
to the sky if you lose
you don't owe me anything but if you win
you could keep it but give me back my
stuff after so i would have people that
would do that
what's also not uncommon are streamers
who have no way of paying these massive
debts back
so they promptly peace the [ __ ] out i'm
not gonna lie to you there's again
there's been a lot of streamers
who would take money from their viewers
and then do the race
they would never show up again like they
would take that and since it's so much
debt
they can't pay it off and they just they
never stream again but for otablock
running was unacceptable so he turned to
his only other option
paying back every single cent
but doing the honorable thing doing the
right thing
it nearly broke him i legitimately think
from how much stress
i went through for that debt i went both
i literally went live
every day bro there was times where i
had to re-microwave my food
six times in order to eat it from how
like like sad i was
oh i would be in college sitting down i
would think i would use
the pinnacle whip noises in the back i
was sitting down and i was just like
i would think i was hearing that in the
back of the room i was like you know
that's how much i was faking like
i was stressed bro like i would sleep
and i would have nightmares of losing a
snake by one hp
now here's the thing oda block kept a
list of names to help him
organize all the people who loaned him
gold
and in order to pay everyone back he not
only relied on his risk fighting ability
he dove deeper into the world of staking
but why the hell would he potentially
dig himself deeper into debt
just to pay it off well for the average
player playing runescape the normal way
paying off that amount of debt is
virtually impossible
to give you some context the best drop
in runescape is worth just over a
billion gold
and there's a complicated process that
gives an average player
a very small chance of earning it from a
raid that takes about 20 to 30 minutes
to complete each time and the best most
consistent money makers in runescape
only earn you about 3 to 4 million gold
an
hour so realistically the only way for
oda block to get out of his hole
was to chase the dragon out the other
[Music]
side
last sneak ever of oldest 258
has been paid
free
and after grinding for multiple hours a
day for five
months after having auditory
hallucinations of his abyssal tentacle
while he tried to sit in the back class
and can learn
oda block finally paid off his gold debt
it's like imagine being in the desert
right like i don't know why i looked at
this water bottle but imagine being in
the desert for like
a week and like that's it you're like
you're thirsty like it is what it is
and then you just grab the watermelon
you're just like like i'm talking about
like some
some crazy cold water bottle you just
drink it that's how it felt it felt
amazing bro
i'm not even lying bro like the stress
on my shoulders when i was in debt
was insane you can feel a palpable sense
of relief
as oda block completes his self-imposed
quest
and earns back his freedom um i would
probably say i'm not even trying to gas
myself
up but i'm the only streamer that if
you're in 258 bills that you would
normally give up and stop streaming and
go ghost
i didn't do that i streamed every day
for five hours straight when i didn't
want to i'd have good nightmares in my
bed be like piss and loss
five bill you acted like it was easy
streaming in 258 build that imagine
every
day you go live and you have to pay back
other people anything you pk is their
money bro 258 but that i paid that [ __ ]
off and you know why because i had my
community on
under my back my viewers helped me yeah
they did i won't deny that
but at the end of the day i went live
every day four or five hours of [ __ ]
day and i didn't give up because i ain't
no [ __ ]
like the rest of these streamers but i
give up and run away from the [ __ ]
debt
in talking with the man he says he's
done getting himself into crazy amounts
of debt
because despite the wow factor that
brought more and more viewers to his
channel
the stress and agony was clearly not
worth it
i was owing people that i really liked i
was only people that like were pulling
the stream like
i had to pay them big and for to me to
pay them all back
and i by the way never again been taking
a loan like i'm
not trying to lose the remainder of my
airline but as hilariously absurd as it
is that he dug himself
in and out of this situation i'm sure
whatever the hell he decides to do next
will be
just as entertaining three two
one zero go
i look like i have a [ __ ] arrow
coming out of my head that's crazy
that's crazy bro like where's the hair
over here i'm 21 years old
well i'm going to turkey by the way for
sure like the staking was like a big
part of the stream at that moment and it
bring a lot of honesty hype around my
stream because like
yo this guy's crazy capture 50 people
check out this baldi you know like [ __ ]
like that